hello and welcome to another episode of
not too deep I'm your host grace Helbig
today we have Hanna burner from Bravo
TVs summer house I'm very excited Hanna
is a new Bravo Liberty she's on summer
house show that documents a bunch of
people working their butts off in New
York and drinking their faces off in the
Hamptons I love it you're gonna love it
she also does stand-up we figure out
what it was like going to the first
Bravo Con
we hear a lot of the behind the scenes
of making a reality television show all
the juicy details that I'm fascinated in
like how many times the sound guy her to
take a [ __ ] it's very very interesting
content enjoy this episode of not too
deep with Hannah burner Hanna this is
very exciting I just watched the newest
episode this morning I love summer house
you do I do it's just like bougie frat
parties every weekend because I lived in
New York and I've never experienced that
world of going out to the Hamptons on
the weekends you're like I feel like I'd
hate those people and then you watch it
to confirm you would hate those yeah
yeah a little bit but also like it seems
it seems fun and as someone that was in
the city and got very panicky and
anxiety ridden about how claustrophobic
it is like I get the idea of like
wanting to get out on the weekend you go
to a place that has space you'll go nuts
if you're just in the concrete jungle
all the time there's something about the
air the second you get out there but I
think in New Yorkers are such extremists
like we work our asses off during the
week yeah and then it's like you party
so hard and it's like we need a little
la mess where it's like do we have plans
maybe I don't know the most la [ __ ]
happened to me and um I was in an
elevator I was talking my friend there
was like seven of us and a minute goes
by and we don't move and someone's like
did anyone hit Lobby yeah I'm like is
everyone hi yeah I need you in New York
people would alike have been like why
the [ __ ] isn't this thing know someone
would have stomped on the elevator floor
until it moved down to the lobby like
people don't give a [ __ ] in New York
people will bust your balls for anything
but here we all just kind of giggled and
I was like say that was a nice exchange
didn't ruin anyone's attack my character
I wasn't torn down for making a mistake
okay let's talk some warehouse explain
the show to someone like an alien that
has no idea this fabulous Bravo reality
programming
well I've loved Brava from the beginning
I think Bravo is incredible at creating
reality shows they are I think they're
great this show in particular is about
that New York lifestyle of being having
a job in the city but when it's
summertime you try to escape and go out
to Long Island which is like this island
that comes out of Manhattan
yeah Queens yeah and you get a share
house because it's so expensive to be
out there so you get a bunch of your
friends and you rent a house right and
you [ __ ] you fight and you do
whatever you want
emotionally right the very sexy Fight
Club on the weekends and then everyone
goes back to New York and they take it
all out at their desk I joke with Paige
he's like my closest friend on the show
yeah it's become just like a drunk psych
ward on the weekends we're like we take
all our [ __ ] from the week and then take
it out it does feel like that so you
came in this show it already existed and
you came in last season of the show so
it had two seasons and I came in on
three okay and so did you know all of
the for lack of a better word cast
members that's what you guys are yeah
before you got on to the show great
question so I feel like our show is not
it has hidden cameras and stuff but it's
not like real world where it lets put a
bunch of people and see how they work
it's about watching a friend group and
that's really the best drama when people
like really care about each other yes
stuff on the line so they were doing a
big recasting after the second season
yeah and they were looking for people
who were like what's the word like not
like really close but like people knew
of me like people never know on the
fringe I wasn't really hard for me okay
so I was actually doing media working
for betches and I was like producing
videos writing memes for them and I was
interviewing some reality TV people
night read summer house and I was like
[ __ ] on them for being on reality TV
and that we're in the city so because we
do media stuff we'd say there Bravo
people and I guess they were recasting
and my name was thrown out there like
Han is outgoing and right single she's
horny and she knows how to be on camera
so she doesn't think before she speaks
or six we're talking people's mouths but
I remember in casting I was like look
I'm actually not that great at drinking
I'm don't really want to be your hot
mess right like I was very scared of
like the Jersey Shore esque this but
even like that's what's fascinating to
me is that like I've grown up to you
watching real world/road rules Jersey
Shore all these shows that you start
when you're like a perceptive person to
understand the dynamics of how reality
TV works you understand the producing
elements of it and you start to meet the
people that do it so you understand like
the characterizing of different types of
people so but you have all this in your
like wheelhouse before going in so you
know shows walked so we could run right
yeah but it must feel like you you have
the tools that to understand like how
they could portray you yeah and I also
was coming from video production like I
was writing little comedy videos mm-hmm
and so I kind of I it was also like my
biggest thing that hurts me in life is
perfectionism which I'm like gotten
really good at because I've been
conscious of it right as in like I mean
you know when you're creating content
you have to just put [ __ ] out there yeah
you could be especially with yourself
yeah like oh why is my laugh sound like
that yeah human you just have to kind of
let stuff go but I basically was like
look if you want to show that women
could be like funny and like strong and
athletic and let me open up about like
my anxieties or depression or I think
ultimately they just want people who
will make mistakes and I like make
mistakes but just not I just don't want
to be like the hot drunk girl right and
everyone now is like oh my god you're
like the relatable one I'm like you guys
think I'm ugly
a hot wine like oh you're so funny on
the show I'm like what am i huh
right do you think so many people go on
TV to be like super aspirational like
I'm on television and it's like you have
to be self-aware people are laughing at
you a lot of the time yeah we're
relating to you right and I wanted to
show that like I could be a mess and
there were things that I struggled with
and like people can go on that journey
with me and I think that was what kind
of it helped me find myself like I
really matured from the show yeah what
was it like cuz you're going and you've
seen the show before yeah I assume I I
wasn't like a watcher of it I mean
honest but then once I was in casting I
need to do my researcher and I'd known
of the show so you you do some research
you go on you have your experience and
in your mind you have your experience
but then it's left to these editors that
now you know craft your experience for
you and so what's watching that first
season that you're on like what's
craziest people are always like is it
real is it real and I think it's in
editing that they just tell there's the
story yeah so if you're at a party like
they could have shown like you know
someone being jealous of me cuz I'm
talking to someone and I'm sad about an
ex but also another side of the room
like Paige is flirting with Karl and
correct so you don't know what they're
ultimately
is right so that's why the show so I
love like mind games it's like a [ __ ]
up game of drunk chess it is hot people
that's what it that's why I watch all
these shows because it really is like
you put a bunch of drunk pin balls in a
pinball machine and you watch them just
like bounce off each other
you know this order is great and it's
it's fascinating or glorifies all those
things but my biggest issue was that I
hate confrontation more than anyone and
that's why I thought it might be bad for
the show yeah but it actually like made
me good because that was such an issue
for me and you see like I was so scared
to confront some people in certain
scenes in the 3rd season like I'd be
whispering like I didn't like other
shows were Vanderpump you could like
blow up on someone be like [ __ ] you can
go to your apartment yeah I'm stuck in a
house with them for three days so you
don't really can't be like [ __ ] you and
walk out right right just walk into
their room right
yeah put me in social situations I'd
never have to be in in real life like I
would never confront some people I would
just talk [ __ ] about them to my friends
like a normal it's like I I mean I think
Lindsay actually taught me a lot because
Lindsay is one those people that gets
stronger with you with confrontation
yeah cuz she is like kind of trust
issues yes make sense but for her to
like you you have to go through [ __ ]
with her yeah it seems like she's got a
little bit of it you can to prove
yourself yeah and at first I was like
white why are we fighting coming not
this is insane I realize she respected
me more when I'd be like no you're
forced to deal with such situations that
you would never do so it forces you to
mature yeah and I think I've really
grown from the show which sounds so
corny but I have but if that's the case
that's the case I also think it's
fascinating because it is one of those
shows like now I'm obsessed with like
the circle and you know love is blind
and on these shows that have the they've
taken out the producers and camera
people in the room with you so much like
they have the cameras in the wall so
you're really getting more I think
candid moments than you would get a
thousand person you guys have a mix it
seems like you have people following you
on the camera obviously but then you
have all of like the GoPros I assume
like in every corner of the house at the
at night like the cameramen leave they
have to sleep right and you sense like a
kind of wildness that happens and we're
all so hammered yeah you guys do some
weird tribal dances like at the end of
every night like this is I think more of
a cult house in a summer house because
at the end of every night Karl's dating
at the time we sacrifice it's always
this like four screen montage of groups
of you throughout different areas of the
house doing some sort of circular like
spinning dance in a circle or ones
dragging one of you into a circle it's a
little sacrificial okay
and I feel like yeah you can tell the
cameraman have gone to bed
you're like the person you set on fire
on a stake outside also gives it away
time with that they just put it in the
montage have you liked the show though
oh it's so fun I also feel like uh
that there's a sense that you in Paige
like have a a sense of you know how the
show works so you're not coming and
you're coming in not jaded but you're
coming and kind of like like more in
control a little bit as much as you can
be for whatever it's worth you need a
show like that because everyone else is
puppeteering everything you know yeah
but it feels like you guys know what you
represent on the show and you don't get
into azmuth messy of situations because
you're like more I think aware like for
me it's an adventure and it's just like
a fun experience that challenges me and
I do I do try to honestly I try to be my
funny silly self and I think for my
first season you didn't see it that much
like people I don't shut the [ __ ] up
like dinner like what I was saying
making fun of the sushi was not
important I think there's some cast
members that have gotten mad being like
I don't worry being so silly like you
have to be serious not to give it away
with my voice I just did a that's me but
be like yours let's say someone's Kyle
selling loverboy like I'm kind of
promoting my personality on the show
like kind of my brand
yeah and that's how I am like I'm either
on or I'm off and during those three
days you got to show up and be on yeah
and but I do also find like you have to
get involved in the mess sometimes it's
just you have to say authentic to how
you would react to it now what do you
think America wants right cuz America is
very smart and consents in authenticity
yeah like the camera magnifies it yeah I
found it it's better just to do you and
then own your [ __ ] if you [ __ ] up
then try to like walk on eggshells and
make everyone be happy which i think is
a life in general yeah I was gonna ask
what was uh what did you notice his
feedback after the first season like
were you overwhelmed with how like well
people were receiving you were you kind
of like nervous about that it was all on
display the only thing that pissed me
off
are you pissed off I'm like well I was
fuming um I wanted to talk about my
tennis cuz my whole life I was like the
tennis player right yeah I wanted to
show like well people were looking up to
me as this like aspirational tennis
player I was dealing with so much
performance anxiety depression I feel
like so many athletes don't get to stop
and think about their mental health yeah
so many great messages that were like I
was a soccer player and that happened to
me it was just it was nice like that but
Bravo they had me do one interview those
like say what happened your tennis
career great and then they had a couple
photos of me and then each episode to
remind everyone they would replay me
talking about it like mini montage like
34 30 might na and people on Twitter
started to like have enough they were
like if this girl talks about tennis one
more time
and I saw a messages like do you play
tennis oh do you play tennis and it
became this like thing that I was so
like this is not what I make from all
this I'm not know whenever I hit I
thought people would be like Hannah
playing tennis again just like me was
like if I was a dude who used to play
professional basketball would people be
like Steve talking about basketball
again real loser so what that was my
awesome but that's good I mean if people
are gonna get upset at you for something
we're annoyed by you for something for
you going out and doing like health
related things I think I'm actually
pretty good with dealing with hate
online because it's I always say like it
if people aren't hating on you not
enough people even like no he water yeah
part of what happens when people know
what I'm doing in your life and I was
like what kind of people are on Twitter
like trying to make strangers feel bad
like your own friends don't do that
stuff right and we only really care what
your friends think right and strangers
but but I do think people were overall I
wasn't involved in as much drama last
season people were just like we love
Hannah and Paige the person that was
great this season I came in hotter and
that's when you get the pan is so
annoying Hannah so immature
oh and it's like whenever a girl is like
a little goofy or a little bit too loud
she were confident in the confidence she
becomes annoying yeah and it's like I
hate that word cuz men are never called
annoying
no matter so [ __ ] annoying I'm just
saying we're equal amounts I think
sometimes people it's a like masculine
quality to be like the funny one yeah
now going one or wanting to be a leader
yeah I'm dealing with these like
especially like older dudes so it can be
clashing but I'm never gonna shut up so
well good for you it's also one of those
things too when you like the idea of
reality television I think prompts
everyone to seek someone to be annoyed
by or the hey and so everyone has their
like you know heat sensors on waiting to
find some flaw in you that they can be
like finally I can hate her great I've
been lookin yeah you're so right if you
think about the flaw it's always [ __ ]
they're projecting on your own
experience it's only insecurity I
definitely remind you of like your
cousin that slept with your boyfriend
don't take it out on Shore cuz like my
voice sounds like I'm not confident
enough to go for a hot guy and you're
going for it and so I now hate you
because you're representing the things
that I've been a little bit I'm so on
this season I think there's this like
hot model dude Luke we are we've heard
little kids in hockey
I think Luke god bless him he's probably
very nice and genuine and Midwest good
but his little is a lot on a lot
I might get literally I was just in a
podcast and they were like how are you
not married to Luke and I was like okay
there's so many issues with that
question first of all good-looking guys
are so crazy in the head I mean you live
in LA you must sure I understand society
teaches us like Disney that princes are
like the ones you need go for they're
the narcissist insecure one the
fucked-up one they'll put you in therapy
yeah like I've dated the I think hot men
sometimes gravitate towards me because
they could tell it's like when you don't
like cats and they keep coming up yeah I
want an ugly hot dude and our monde was
like this cool dude who I normally go
for Luke types and I was connecting with
this guy mostly and I was like Hanna
this is an epiphany this is what you
need for a happy relationship
but look he he's so good-looking I
couldn't help it yeah but I also think
that with women you have to understand
those looks fade
yes about obviously what really matters
which is how biggest it is yeah okay
we're gonna take a quick break when we
get back I have a billion more questions
we'll be right back with more not too
deep today we have some sponsorship from
Sports
Research it's your one-stop shop for a
lifetime of performance health and
wellness they're the makers of the
highest-rated collagen peptide product
on Amazon and their flagship product
sweet sweat sweating helps burn calories
and sweet sweat activated by your
elevated heart rate helps increase
sweating during exercise you simply
apply the gel which comes in a variety
of pleasing cents too slow to respond
problem areas before you workout for
best results use sweet sweat in
combination with sports researches
best-selling waist trimmers if that's
something that you're into and did you
know that collagen is vital to support
the health of your skin hair nails and
connective tissues that's why you should
try sports researches third party
certified and non-gmo verified collagen
peptides which provide the best product
at the best price offered in a variety
of flavors sports research collagen
peptides can be added to coffee the soup
de sauces or more on the go or at home
whatever you prefer and they've sent me
some of their stuff I tried their sweet
sweat one the coconut smells amazing
I've put it on the person before I've
worked out and it does actually help
increase sweating Elliot actually uses
it every day when he works out and he
looks like a glistening God so if you're
interested I recommend we have a special
offer for you guys if you go to sports
research calm and use offer code grace
grac e at checkout right now
you'll get 20% off your order that's 20%
off site-wide at sports research comm
with the promo code grace at checkout
okay let's get back into it so this
season
this episode will come out I believe in
the season will still be going on
I need hints any any things you can
tease that I think this season you see
people fight that you never thought
would fight hmmmm it's chosen the trait
trailer me and Paige have like Oh a huge
muh were like if we're going to have a
fight it needs to be the most epic like
burn the house down fire did you pre
plan a fight Oh God you can't where I
was like we would never fight but if we
did it would have to be there be a very
high tree sleep with your [ __ ] boy
yeah
and children raise them anyway so when
we fight we both like didn't expect it
and it was a very it's real it was a
roast yeah and I think a lot of people
that's what they asked is it real and
it's like it is real but it's also like
you know when it's almost inception like
there's a new reality in what it is yeah
even our conversation right now like
we're kind of performing but there still
is like we're still dealing with each
other yeah you guys are existing in the
world that you all are on the conscious
level knowing that you nailed it it's
hard to explain beYOU know that that's
why I'm fascinated cuz I also I want to
every reality TV I love married at first
sight to no one have you seen that show
but I was just a little stone with my
boyfriend watching it and I was like
this isn't how I thought this is a
genuine thought I'm more curious to be
like a PA on that sex I want to see when
cameras go down how they talk to each
other differently than when the cameras
are rolling cuz you know you have your
on-camera persona I mean and then you
guys have you know the the liquor that
surges through that brings the veil off
a little bit more but I'm sure that you
know the real fights that happen are
ones because so you forget that your
existing in this world yeah and it's
also that it's impossible to keep that
like on-camera persona yeah I think when
I first started it I lasted like two
days and then I was like this is
exhausting he's gonna just be myself
I was literally trying to like nail
every line I said and they annoy me stop
looking down the length of the camera
see they laughed at me and also I always
thought I was like I have to me because
I've known issues with tennis like never
getting deep when I would perform well
I'd get like positive affirmation when
I'm so like I was like seeking yes
you're like if I make people laugh
people like me but then it's so weird
out people will like you almost more
when you're just being like boring when
you're authentic and because they were
just so [ __ ] boring that some people
connect yeah I guess there's two sides
like people can laugh at me but I think
they more enjoy how you make them feel
when they feel connected to you oh yeah
I mean like you falling down drunk at
like the 4th of July party that's shown
for like three seconds
like I love this moment Luke is like
shaking his head and I'm like hey it
blows my mind what's it like now being a
Bravo Liberty as I used to say it
probably is wild because I'm like you
yeah I love Bravo um Millionaire
Matchmaker was SMO yeah when I was going
through a depression Vanderpool's got me
out of it like after work you go home
and you're just like I need to lose
myself in someone else's life yeah it
was just incredible these are my friends
now yeah we're family and I I think I
didn't expect also not someone I didn't
apply to any reality shows never I apply
for the bachelor I didn't see that for
myself
mm-hmm and it just kind of happened and
now I like but I I'm I think I hate to
do this to you but I am inspired by you
like not to make you feel awkward but I
remember like growing up on the subway
I saw your advertisement oh yeah yeah on
the subway a weird YouTube and I was
like that's a badass [ __ ] he was just
creating content she's not waiting for
people and I see my Bravo as just like a
journey like I like being a brother
Liberty and making friends with other
raava liberties but I also see it as
just a launching pad to give me exposure
to
more of my own content well I mean it's
one it's working and I'll show you a
kudos to you because you can tell it's
the kind of person you are I mean like
you reached out to me last year and like
you're hustling and being like yeah and
I was like I admire this like energy
around all of this because that's what
you do have to do you and I appreciate
your collaborative energy to be like
join the class but it's also I think
it's goodto that you're like you're
leaning into it maybe that's not the
right way but you're like saying yes to
this is the world that you do exist in
not trying to like shy away from it cuz
yeah I I can imagine that doing the
reality TV thing and then also trying to
do like stand-up and legit comedy that
people probably try like [ __ ] on you a
little bit from coming from that world
ocean New York it's tough yeah I was
fortunate that I had I dated a stand-up
comedian before I got into comedy so you
had that like legitimacy look I kind of
knew the world's like I I knew a lot of
the comedian's and their matches I
started like hiring these just like
talented comedians with no following
till he be on these betches videos so I
started making like real friends and I
realize now I was falling in love with
comedy not necessarily the guy but I
fell in love with it and I finally was
like we broke up and I was like if
you're gonna do stand-up you have to
make sure you want to do this cuz this
is like his world and it would be like
it's a small tight-knit community in the
city and in LA yeah and finally I
started my podcast and I did a live show
my friend was like do ten minutes a
comedy cuz I mean tweeting is like kinds
of jokes I think you so much material
uh-huh and you with tweets you they're
like make it like the button of the joke
the punchline or just a bigger concept
like I had all this stuff and I was like
fine and I do Tim it's a comedy and
everyone after was like that was the
best part wow I was like oh [ __ ]
I wasn't I didn't I was you know you
suppress some things Bello yeah it's
probably yeah like I needed to like out
myself yeah the hardest part of being
stand-up is saying that you want to be a
stand-up right because you already have
the name
crush your dreams hate yourself sabotage
in you which is what stand-ups have and
you got me to admit that feels
narcissistic in a way to be like I want
to do something like stand-up scares the
[ __ ] out well the idea of doing like
people want to listen to you talk for an
hour all right wrap them it's like just
a really long voicemail 30 seconds
you're like this is boring yeah but I do
think in the comedy community I had a
couple people be like okay if you want
to do this
people are gonna put you on their shows
just cuz you were following and if you
don't do well everyone's gonna know
they're gonna talk [ __ ] that people just
put you on because you're following if
you want to do this you have to like
bomb and bars small open mics and that
kind of stuff if you want to do it let's
do it and I have some people in the
community who kind of took me under
their wing that's again collaborative
and I and I feel like that's why I've
had so many people reach out like how to
get involved I'm like we need more women
obviously and stand up yeah and I think
one of the biggest reasons why now I
realize women are in stand-up is the
lifestyle so not conducive for a woman
like all right now I'm not getting the
best spots in New York so I'll have like
a midnight show in Brooklyn yeah and I
can't say no to it but do I as a single
girl want to go all the way to a brand
new bar in Brooklyn full of random men's
yeah and then like show and have people
laugh at me and then leave like it's a
tough lifestyle alone yeah it's scary
yeah the actual practical sense inside
of like trying to hustle yeah he's
difficult difficult so I but I've been
putting in that grind I think that's
what has given me the confidence and you
you have to put respect to the art that
you're doing but also they're respecting
that the art is changing yeah these same
comics are the ones who really can you
help me you know put together a video
clip of my set right or or you know I
should tweet more you're right like
comic starting to post their tweets and
stuff so we're both realizing like we
need each other yeah there's a mutual
crossing over oh that's great I do think
there's still that like old you know
like white man perspective that's like
comedy is just like a dude saying like
racist sexist jokes onstage and like
they will die out soon and it's just
it's cool seeing comedy evolve and
somebody
like you understand Oh totally the it's
also must be fascinating to the kind of
audiences that are coming to your shows
because I there does feel like a
difference between like people that go
to comedy shows and know like what it is
and then reality TV fans that come and
enjoy you as you that's another thing so
like this little [ __ ] talking I have
some comics will be like as in like your
crowd isn't a comedy crowd right I'm
having a great night he's amazing i
played dynasty typewriter last night oh
yeah
and pete lee messaged me uh who is that
in credit one of my favorite comics and
he was just like hey can i do a guest
spot and i was like oh my god i'm so
honored yes 100% and he finished he
looks at me he goes great crowd and i
was like [ __ ] yeah my people he's a real
comic because also people who like me
don't just like me for somewhere else
and i think yeah for women men trying to
be successful is i'm trying to have a
variety of different like streams of
income coming in where like summer house
ends tomorrow what you could Instagram
goes down tomorrow right you have
different opportunities for yourself the
best way to think about it just keep all
the pots on the stove don't burn the
water have you had a memorable fangirl
moment from meeting any of the other
Bravo reality stars great question cuz
we had nene leakes on a few months ago
and it was I still can't believe it
happened and just her walking in was
just like oh my god yeah we don't have
to record you can just sit and look
wonderful fun conversation it was great
she was just like very exactly what I
imagined her to be that's why I like
when you interview actors you're like
wait you're you're not even British you
are but reality TV people I feel like
they're pretty the same yeah Bravo Khan
oh yeah what's that like I've never been
I'm a fact one time I highly recommend
you go okay wild they did a massive
convention a massive convention around
the
Bravo and all the top Bravo liberties
are just like roaming right it's like
going to Africa and sing just like
Safari so I I get there they had our
first thing was like a late-night thing
cuz somebody else isn't like the most
respected show yet right I feel like you
guys in below deck they sort of like
keep on hand and the housewives like
true thing Vanderpump is like always
amazing and I feel like summer house is
getting there yeah and this last season
is so epic oh cool
just letting you know I know but I walk
in I'm like only when I'm I see someone
and just Lisa Vanderpump holding Giggy
what just standing there the first
people and I turned her mostly and she's
just as glamorous as ever Giggy as
adorable as you think oh I did not have
the balls to speak I would be too scared
I was scared I was scared
um I all I also um I was with Paige and
we saw Reza oh you guys at sunset which
i think is an amazing show uh-huh
and I was again you're kind of scared
cuz you've seen these people like
imagine if everyone has seen you in your
weirdest moments Oh in the most
vulnerable yeah exactly but you feel
like you're friends with them and you
know everything about them but you're
embarrassed to admit that you know
everything you know but they know that
that's why they exist on TV is so that
you know everything about that but
you're not seeing them like doing well
at brunch feeling good mental breakdown
like hammered blackout Hannah yeah so we
see Reza at this news thing we're doing
press and he like he kind of make eye
contact he walk but he walks biased and
we once on summer house people went out
one night and we were literally watching
Shahs of Sunset on her bed while we're
getting filmed by the camera watching
Bravo's so meta
Wow so we see him like oh my god and
then we like walk by him again and we're
like oh my god we love him and we're in
our green room and we got a knock on the
door and it's Reza and he's goes I just
let you guys know summer house is so
good this season
like I'm from New York I don't care to
make anyone comfortable like I don't
have to say that I said something to him
yeah the fact he was so nice and then it
makes me be like I can't wait for like a
new show to come on but you can have
that moment what's that moment to be
like dude we're all in it together it's
so easy to be a dick yeah I I like the
the reality people that have the
awareness and like the a little bit of a
self deprecation of knowing like what
they are on TV and that I don't know
there's something very likeable about
that I had a heart-to-heart with scheana
recently oh yeah scheana I was like
having a rough time the beginning of the
season like yeah some dude said she's a
bad kisser and yeah she's really getting
this like mean girl at it yeah and I was
like getting to know her and she wanted
my podcast and I was like dude you look
like a [ __ ] you're not that you look
really mean and she was just kind of
complaining about like it's not cool
that you know Dana gets her comedy show
first episode and scheana they don't
show any of her stuff and she's just
like I hate that they just show him
boy-crazy all-time blah blah and I was
like dude everyone's boy-crazy like yeah
that's how relatable you are yeah and I
was like you have to embrace that and
she she's now like creating this like
boy-crazy brand while she's starting to
be like self-aware like you can't drink
the kool-aid yeah like you have to
realize that your peoples background
entertainment yeah yeah well they're
living their life take yourself too
seriously
right you have to monetize it you have
to put it on be nice yeah that's why the
Housewives make original music when none
of them in their lives should ever make
original music anything good as gold
is iconic it's great it are you for
yelling I was very passionate about that
it's fantastic have you guys I mean
there is loverboy feel like it's the
most tangible like you know product
offshoot on the show are there any
others I really think this show has
hopefully this season my podcasts
burning in hell yeah you saw me think of
it as an ideal a seasoned dinner promo
and it's like Red Devil outfit yeah it's
like where I talk to people about their
demons and it's like a dark comedy
and this season you get to see me like I
was interviewing Drake Bell which was
quiet and strange but he's like
publicist reached out and I was like
he's my childhood my childhood yes bring
him in I'd like to meet him
no he's great but you get to see that um
because yeah we don't have a tangible
thing I think Paige has been done but a
bunch of like fashion stuff and it's
it's just it's hard yeah well okay in
the same realm of tangible things I
started to read stuff about like you
talking to why there's so many packages
delivery to the house every week and I
was like that is a good question why are
there so many freaking packages really
legit questions I thing is these shows
we actually are the worst part about
summer house is we are so responsible
for things yeah like we're responsible
to like kind of pick what the party's
gonna be order any stuff we want for the
party that's kind of refreshing to hear
that it is they basically will be like
this is a summer house yeah you guys are
actually it's a real we have to go get
the horse part is we have to like
prepare the parties like we decorate the
parties yeah and then we have to clean
up the [ __ ] party so you guys are
actually hosting a summer and like yeah
so the Amazon stuff is like they'll be
alcohol that some people do get like
their own packages shipped there we
always have outfits that we need to get
so we'll get it shipped there to make
sure it's there and every yeah we always
have some make sense cuz it does seem
like without it being mentioned it just
kind of is always there and it's
presented like we dressed direct Amanda
orders it one weekend like she
accidentally ordered it late and we
didn't get it sent I literally ate like
Turkey and jello shots it's like we need
that food that's what I'm people like a
wet is that I'm like it's actually like
way realer than you thought yeah this is
like art supplies
further we need okay we're gonna take
one last break when we get back with a
bunch of Twitter questions for you
so we'll be right back with more not too
deep
[Music]
- hey guys we're taking a break from the
podcast real quick to do some promotion
of ourselves that's right yes we are
promoting ourselves little reminder to
you guys out there that if you go into
the Apple podcasts and you rate and
review not too deep it's a beautiful
wonderful helpful thing for us and for
you guys it helps people find our
podcast that helps us hear what you guys
like what you don't like etc and we just
appreciate you taking the time again
go to Apple podcast leave us a rating
review whatever you want okay we're back
and we're gonna get into these Twitter
questions before we do I'm gonna ask you
the two questions asked every single
guest that is on the podcast and the
first is who alive or dead would you
most want to throw cold spaghetti at
they always ask who you loved the most
no I'm like who do I hate yeah it's your
choice oh my god well first of all cold
spaghetti is actually pretty good it
really enhances the flavor yeah it could
be a good thing it could be someone you
look up to oh this is wild I would like
to throw cold spaghetti yet you know I I
want to [ __ ] with Chelsea Handler oh
yeah because she is my inspiration I
actually taught tennis to her once whoa
I've read all her books and I literally
don't read books yeah and she um I feel
like she gave me my inspiration for like
that you could be like mean to dudes and
it's hysterical so I'd love for us to be
like mean to each other and like see who
could outputs each other and make each
other laugh I could see a hangout
session of just like a ping-pong
back-and-forth of spaghetti being thrown
yeah it is just conversation being had
and that's like she's from new Jers and
I think that I show affection is being
mean to each other yeah literally you'll
see two people from the East Coast
having a conversation it sounds like
they're arguing when they're just like
agreeing with each other yeah yeah the
tone you're just like I don't know
you're right about that and I think it's
- yeah it's a very like out yessing each
other are out supporting each other very
aggressive aggressive
overall I think Iceman sir that's a
great answer okay the other question is
every single guess is to tell us your
worst pants [ __ ] story or close call
but you can only use three words or
small phrases so mine is college jogging
front lawn great time starting with
college I knew it's gonna be messy yeah
mine is New York City bodega Oh No
risky fart yeah
ruined leggings I the only okay thing is
that I feel like bodegas have seen so
much crazy [ __ ] I was the classiest one
in there yeah you are thriving okay
let's get into some Twitter questions
someone's know-how is butter butter
actually of a necklace this is your cat
here's my cut do you have a dog give a
dog yeah but butters a great name for a
cat I love food names are like real
human names like Jennifer's yeah Steven
Mia butters great she's a cat who was
actually in the found in the dumpster in
the Bronx oh no and my friend took her
into foster her but my friend wasn't
really cat person and didn't know how to
get her out from under the bed oh they
called me and I worked my cat whispering
magic and then like animals pick you I
really think yeah they pick you and she
picked me and I had to tell my roommates
I'll give a [ __ ] if you're allergic or
whatever she chose me wow that's that's
butter story and so how long have you
had her I've had her for a little over a
year and this is this trip has been hard
without our you know when you're like
having the memes like you're having fun
with your friends
yeah is your pets home alone yeah like a
couple of those you're like smiling and
then it turns into Lily have you
ventured into the world of like the pet
cams oh my gosh I'm not there yet cuz I
yeah I think I'd get upset and miss them
more yeah any dogs I think needed a
more than cats I feel like cats would be
a little bit more elusive and that you
would probably get your money's worth
I've been getting them on camera yeah
like you don't even I get I don't have a
cat sitter I have someone who layer just
goes in changes her litter and puts
fooding cuz she's like don't be here
they jokes people like your cat when you
think she's got you're gone and she's
like all sad it's like actually your cat
and she's just rolling around because
they're so self-sufficient they're like
how do we even like consider them pet
great there's this crazy bond where they
say I know a lot about cat to catch up
they say that cats are like they're not
domesticated just since like Egyptian
times that just always hung around
humans and there's this weird like they
they love need us and love us it's a
weird it's hard to explain the
connection but they also kind of train
us like we train dogs they kind of train
us yeah
you're my human now and this is what I
need I feel like they have an
understanding that they were seen as
gods and goddesses and that that's how
they are meant to be treated no Tigers
in your gray and they accept nothing
less than like the optimum treatment the
best is like you'll whenever you go to
do work and you pull out anything
they're like this is where I'm gonna lie
when they do in your leg oh yeah cat
falls asleep on my pillow I'm like I
guess I'm sleeping under the pole cats
just have terrible PR like Marley & Me
yeah Air Bud that ugly basketball happy
Bowl and my cats have the cat movie that
lost millions of dollars in box office
yep and the reviewer said the movie
ruined his life yeah that's what I'm
doing
someone said I was have you ever given
or been given a wedgie
I feel like this has been on the show I
feel like I have a wedgie all the time I
wear granny panties cuz I hate wedgies
that much really yeah like full ass not
like little boy shorts they're just like
a constant watch and I hate it have you
do you guys on the show have any like
unspoken or spoken rules of boundaries
that like with we're gonna make sure
none of us do this on camera I think
well there is the boundary of like do
you want 40 producers to see your tits
or not right it would take a lot of us
change in the closet or the bathroom
right right which is weird to like I'll
go home and like do that in my own house
and I'm like oh my god the cameras
aren't here right because you guys have
cameras in your bedroom it's all you're
always being seen and you're always
being listened to
yeah I get it because you're always
having a mic on you so like go to take a
poop and I'm like is everyone the same
[Music]
have you is there anything that you are
thankful hasn't made the show or
anything that you're like I didn't even
know that that had happened well I was
doing interviews where they basically
will say like this happened what's your
opinion alright and they were like so
you were FaceTime your mind you hung up
and then you flashed your boob at Luke
oh yeah and the hot tub and I was like
my worst nightmare and as I thought
about it was like a blip you know he's
my reason or like a blip I didn't think
twice about it I kinda buzzed like yeah
and I was like was it really after right
after her mom they were like yep and I
was like are you sure do like 100% I
roll the tape I do think yeah there's I
also I like to jump in the pool during
parties yeah it's so funny they treat us
like little but you have a mic cousin
right exactly so in summer camp yeah
they do just like at summer camp because
season one I was like fireball and just
two bran and jumped in and with a mic on
a sound guy didn't talk to me for like
six months or so much it's like $5,000
mic oh so now they're like Hannah and
I'm like you're hammered up I'm like
what they're like if you want to go in
the pool you have to take your mic off
I'll take it
I want to go on the oh okay and then I
like jump in the pool and then my makeup
is everywhere and of course that's when
like someone important start stalking me
like who comes to the hot tub when I'm
just peeing sitting in my own pee a hot
tub trying to enjoy myself and he's like
hey how do you feel about our Mons and
I'm like cross-eyed with mascara
everywhere like the beginning of the
party I put effort and then by the end
you're like at least you know for
continuity Paige is like crying to me at
one of the parties yeah and I'm standing
there with my makeup just all [ __ ] up
and my eyes are kind of crossed you know
when you're trying to focus okay and you
could tell it's important yeah and I had
this like dumb drunk like kind of smile
be okay I'm sometimes like why it's kind
of smiling while Paige is crying and I'm
like because I'm literally trying to be
conscious stay standing
I know that I have a secret in my head
[Laughter]
someone to know if you had one
superpower but could only use it one
time in your life what would it be it
was oh my god this is so stuff one yeah
this is like I'm gonna go too deep but
it would be like to clear up a trauma oh
yeah that's a great item ajan if you
could be like oh that time is like
really affected me and I want to like if
I could just take that out of my time
line you're a fire and want to like be
well that's I mean cuz that's kind of
why you started your podcast right yeah
I need to talk about like people's
anxieties and fears and demons and that
sort of thing has that been really
helpful for you and they seem so helpful
I started cuz I was meeting all these
people who I looked up to yeah and was
actually talking to them and realizing
that they're so [ __ ] up like it's is I
used to think like is LeBron James
happier than everyone else yeah yeah I'm
like that's not really like is that fair
that there's people like who are
successful and so much happier than
everyone that I realized I didn't
comprehend that like that stuff has
nothing to do with happiness and I
really wanted to take people who we look
up to and be like what is your biggest
physical insecurity what keeps you up at
night and I realize we are all the same
yeah it's a how you cope with it or be
some people are so successful because
they have literal bad issues and it's
the only thing that keeps them like I
mean it's talking about Bravo yeah so
enabling bad behavior yeah but I have
realized just how people are so similar
and it's I got to talk to people and and
have those close talks that I always
want to ask someone but it'll be weird
but because I see my podcast ain't cool
that it's yeah it's okay it's a safe
space to have them yeah like imagine
finding like the most beautiful woman in
the world and you're like what are you
physically insecure ago and she was like
are you gonna pull out a marker and so I
was circling my fat and I was like it
just gets like really but um it's been a
really cool experience
that's awesome who's like a dream guest
for you on that I do I'd like to have a
mission where oh yeah that's the end
Chelsea I love my son Chelsea I think
Amy like grew up and in the same like
New York City comedy and Harry and I
know a lot about her but I've I've met
her like once or twice but in a in a
quick way yeah yeah yeah I think that'd
be cool I'd love to listen to that
what's it like to be Bernie Sanders so
many people are asking this question to
be Bernie to be Bernie yeah it's um I'm
the presidency it's been going well
people say I look old which is messed up
[Laughter]
superficial part someone's no favorite
career memory oh okay this is gonna be a
wild but my favorite current memory is
getting fired from betches really yeah I
think it's the best thing that happened
to me ever why'd you get fired if you I
think I got fired because I it was a
place I was like the seventh hire I'd
build the video team there I loved it
I'm not super familiar with that Jason
it's like a media company I have like
they've written books they have a
website it started with a like blog yeah
they have a very popular Instagram
they're creating videos and
so fun but then like summer house came I
realized I wanted my own podcast I was
my own voice and they kind of were like
you're distracted and I do think that
like I was working really hard but they
kind of I'd like hit a glass ceiling
there and I'd never quit because I
really loved my job but they were
basically like this isn't a good fit
anymore and then the second that door
closed I saw these other doors opening
we're like I would have never been doing
stand-up I would have never met the
people I've met so cool being fired is
[ __ ] awesome is it sometimes a true
blessing yeah it's like like get fired
people like looking back and when you've
been broken up with and hating at the
moment but then realizing like that was
very helpful like whoever did that up
there thank you exactly
well speaking to that someone's no do
you often think about changing careers
or do you think the one you have now is
set I think that nothing is ever set and
I think cuz every you're evolving the
media is evolving but changing careers
is like I was in sales and marketing and
I [ __ ] hate it yeah and yeah I like I
quit because I was just like I don't
care how much money I'm making I'd
rather be happy and I just thought
whenever I feel disconnected I'm like
what's it han I like doing as a kid like
who's your inner child yeah I was always
silly always creative and I I hope that
I changed and have new I even joke like
I hope when I'm old I'm like painting on
a farm with like tons of cats and
animating true to your child yeah I
don't want to be doing traveling doing
stand-up forever at some point I want to
settle down on a farm that's great thank
you those are great goals just
watercolor and sell it on whatever the
new social media yeah whatever the
tic-tock evolution becomes I don't know
stresses me out
yeah well what is what's next are you do
you guys know if you do a season then we
don't know if we're renewed yet okay I
do think like people like you supporting
is so huge because it's one of those
shows it's actually the only Bravo show
the last five years that's been renewed
because it's really difficult with like
competing with Netflix and everybody I
like Vanderpump a while ago didn't have
that competition right right yeah we're
really fighting to like be seen but
and I do think the show took a while to
get it this legs your legs it's also
unique because it is so seasonally based
you know you can't just pick up a
production team and shoot it whenever
you want like you really have to be over
the course of the summer in my heart of
hearts I think they're definitely gonna
give us another season but uh we'd start
filming in the summer obviously and
you're always welcome to summer house
party if you want to make that decision
I I would love the drop I for one second
o'clock all the cameras and all the
corners and then call a quick uber and
Irish goodbye everyone that sounds like
me at most parties yeah what else do you
have going on for people that do not
know okay so Hannah Byrne calm I have my
stand up so I'm gonna be in Texas I'm
gonna be in Jersey Connecticut Wisconsin
Florida sweet and they can find all the
information on your social and my social
app being burnt and listen to me I'm
burning in hell yeah my my podcast and
I'd love to have you on open invitation
either up to Center in the city hit me
up will do okay before you go every
guest that makes time for us gets a
personalized fortune cookies to you so
you can near any medians whenever oh my
god no it's in there don't worry
everyone before they leave leave them
feeling someone wanted oh my god this is
so good if you follow the ways of Marie
Kondo we believe you can easily fit in a
BDSM dungeon easily fit a BDSM dungeon
in New York City apartment believe in
yourselves just fold more yeah guys are
amazing like we try to help those the
circle right here to help thank you for
making time and being here this was so
fun thank you so much for having me I'm
excited to watch the rest of the season
everyone out there go listen to the
podcast go check out check you out live
wherever they can go on the socials see
all of it and I can't wait to see how
many more mullets get worn throughout
the rest of the season that seems like a
viable product that could be made did
you say I put it in my babies
yeah in a new word after he didn't know
so if that's I mean I don't know how
that didn't make the cut but whatever
we'll see you guys next
I'm not too deep goodbye 2deep 2deep
2deep 2deep was headed back not too deep
is a production of grace helbig
incorporated producer Melissa D months
edited by Shireen Lonnie Eunice post
production sound by Chris Henry and an
extra special thanks to Flula for the
theme music
[Music]